this intro was very long and winding it
was five minutes of complete nonsense
and unsensibility elixir and what we're
going to do is we're going to cut out
all that crap and I'm gonna we're gonna
engage on a different level okay all
right
let's even figure out a smooth way to
get from the intro the high listen we're
back with another episode of Shadows
overloathing we got into Murray's but
Murray isn't here because Murray is
actually into he's my uncle but the
antique store is actually a front to go
get exotic artifacts that are haunted
and we are on a responsible mission to
go take those artifacts and take them
away and there's also a person named
Gabby or a goblin named Gabby which
looks very familiar from the Goblin from
the first or second Wester loathing
which is actually the second in the
series
we're about to go to the newspaper store
and then we're gonna go get a hat that's
haunted and we're gonna kill it lyxian
that was also way too long make it even
more succinct from that
we're gonna go kill a hat no he's at the
desk okay handyman oh
oh caliope
caliopia
no sardines okay Colo Wars plus store
need some sardines
okay you open the door and there's
there's a brick wall behind it
apparently goes nowhere well that's good
glad for that Texas is not gonna let you
sleep until you get that hat I guess
I'll go get that hat
wait there was something oh yeah Cola
Wars Surplus right
where was this newspaper place also how
do I get into Cold War Surplus given the
current conditions dark and stormy you
probably shouldn't wander into any
alleys all right whatever you say oh
this one wait what's over here
Securus
um nothing interesting over there I
don't care
all right
hello any haunted hats note says Robson
first hinden then Carver who's next
Venable says if Burgess comes comes from
him he's gonna karate job his desk
enough sincerely Curtis Curtis PS what's
karate I that whole letter was confusing
reporters cufflinks
who left says always check right says
your sources I appreciate that did I
equip that
oh what did that replace
gloves I don't need hot armor I need
mysticality because that happens to go
inside with my spatula Hindu I'm not
paying you to publish kakamami
conspiracy theories in fact I'm not
paying you at all clean out your desk
and hit the road yes do you like the
word cockamami that I used up there it's
a slang term I coined it means
ridiculous or implausible I think it's
really gonna catch on yes also you're
fired
letter reads Reginald I think Burgess is
on to us we've gotten careless in fact
maybe I shouldn't be typing this out as
a letter instead I'm just talking to you
in person why am I doing this meet me
under the water cooler this afternoon ah
crap Here Comes Burgess with a pink slip
it doesn't say who it's from the writer
must have gotten fired before they could
type their name also under the water
cooler what's that about government
corruption at an all-time high the
government is once again slash funding
to the city services and social program
deciding waste but without offering any
supporting figures or explaining where
the funds have been reallocated to
additionally Anonymous sources report oh
it cuts off abruptly maybe as a result
of the pink slip next to the typewriter
Curtis I've told you once I've told you
100 times not enough people buy the
paper anymore to keep the lights on in
this joint electricity is expensive
because it's a very recent Innovation as
such fully half of your salaries paid by
government subsidies we go back way back
buddy but you've given me no choice
clean out your desk and scram
ble on softly nice that he wrote it in a
letter hey coffee
I gotta ask the old coffee can I drink
that one or am I not allowed to drink
anyone increase your maximum AP until
you use another potion
what's a potion I can't even drink that
one pneumatic tube operating I'm
operating
looks like the eye had some
state-of-the-art delivery infrastructure
I guess
oh boy without anything specific you
waste your time I doubt that I'll let
you know when I'm wasting my time hello
oh
tragic accidents starting to have no
consequences hiramo crawlins owner of
the first mass-produced commercial
automobile restaurant in the state
accidentally struck the hitchhiker
the notion that vengeful spirits of the
Dead might haunt the places of their
demise and murderers phantasmagoric rage
has been rejected by modern science as
rather unlikely wouldn't you say
unlikely sure yeah
oh
God you don't know what went into this
bag but you know that the only thing
that's ever going to come out of it is a
congealed mass of falgu glad I put that
in my pocket it's a big heavy water
cooler and it's got something to hide
move oh
all right
no need to dump fish
I always suspected it would be fish
people it's an underground press
literally there's still a newspaper left
in there oh this was printed in a secret
underground newspaper office
okay there's a huge black skull scrawled
on July 22nd 1917. what happened that
day how could I ever know oh
consult the manual
Bush green
oh my god do I need to even need to read
this no I'm going to use my Superior
memory to get this on the first try push
green power button pull the pump engage
ladder adjust the suction rate according
to the pressure Diagnostics if red
section A if blue suction e if green d
red a blue E green D green D blue e red
a red a green D blue E green d a red a
blue e to abort red power off button so
watch the indicator
needs to be perfect green button go
boink satisfying click you hear a motor
starting somewhere I'm gonna pull the
lever
yellow is glowing
uh
oh
okay red a blue E green d a b c d e f
or if it's yellow yellow is a
combination of green and blue
no I don't know
you
know
it's a rainbow
what does a rainbow look like it's a
rainbow
so yellow is C
yellow is C
oke
they're dead
damn I'm good well someone gonna give
some very strange mail and how
what were those things what were they
doing here were they trying to start an
underwater newspaper that wouldn't work
the inkwood spear I didn't even get to
talk to him I'm just too smart
it was a rainbow everybody all right
what is this ah top story ocean City's
comptroll is passing of an overly
complicated sidewalk right-of-way policy
that outlawed Streetside newspaper
vending machines and limited the maximum
allowance
I don't care about any of this at least
I got some XP I'll do the muscle it's
important to do because of certain
story-wise things to open and close
doors
anyways this is A Haunted Hat what's
with the shadowed outline of someone
Anonymous vaguely person-shaped stain is
on the ground
well nothing to worry about that for me
it's a hat I got a terribly cursed
Fedora a simple black felt Fedora it
doesn't look cursed but it has a
palpable ore of Menace about it nothing
good can come of this I'm gonna equip it
nice probably a horrible mistake but God
damn do I look good while
you decide you won't be needing that
pneumatic tube operating manual after
all I'm returning to the disc you grab
from
all right cool
I have a cursed hat la la la look at my
curse I am cursed forever and ever
looks like you found the Hat I found a
hat I guess it's the one you want
doesn't look unusual although yeah well
it does creep me out a bit I can't
really put my finger on why I know what
you mean feels kind of like you have a
headache except you don't really
actually more like a feeling of dread
like something terrible is about to
happen but I don't know what it is yet
yeah it's definitely not related to the
fact that I need you to take the hat and
go sit in the machine over there why
it's our uncursing machine gotta get the
curse off the hat right ah okay yeah it
makes sense but man can we just put the
hat in the machine why do I need to be
involved because the machine needs a
mind the god dealing cursing process
together you'll lift the curse from the
hat and transform it into a sort of
allegorical dream space that the machine
can transfix
all right I'm assuming some of you got
what that was but I didn't feel like
hello
chess
hi
you must be Charles Wallace
of course please do me Mark what do you
do around here General handy oh handyman
built the detectotron and the uncursing
Machine that's some real high-tech
Wizardry oh it's nothing it's nothing
how does it work I only Built the thing
can't tell you how it works the innards
are all wild up to a little porcelain
cat figure that Murray found somewhere
that's weird yep
nothing right now you want to play chess
uh no I mean never learned Jessica sure
I don't remember how to I don't I'm not
good at I'm not good at what is
how do I respond I'm gonna I'm gonna
skewer a bishop
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do be a queen
ah God damn it all right terribly cursed
Fedora go for it
no certain if you sat down the machine
with a hiss a positively whiffs the
fazure straight up into the Dome the Hat
rattles around and they're angrily like
a snake and a cement mixer and after a
good loud minute flops limp and wet into
your lap whatever ominous energy once
possessed a terrible curse hat is gone
it is now simply a terrible hat but the
curse itself still lives transfixed as a
dream-like construct within the machine
now how do I get rid of that curse
curses are like energy that can't be
created or destroyed destroyed only
changed Newton Newman Newton Newton
Isaac Newton Newman Newton Newton Newman
yeah the machine knows how to take a
curse from one object and put it in
itself but as far as how you change a
curse I don't know that's some higher
Consciousness all right oh I'm doing it
now
who is this who who am me
ah
interesting I'm me or I'm the curse I
don't oh God
I heard thy death call creature what
does that even mean rest now I will find
in the moral
tree fell before its time a ground
stained with sin yes at in Arcadia ego
even on Arcadia there's death even in
Paradise there is a killer I whatever
okay you got it buddy wow thou know who
I am and why I'm here I coulda there has
been a murder
but no thou have murder thou I did not
do the murderer and that is all what
more have they for me honest I am one of
three brothers why am I always telling
the truth I am already alive
uh
and if I find a liar there's nothing
there's no thing I can do to save in
thee I cut her thou are a servant of the
wood Blessed Be Your branches
blessed to be nice hats well there's
only honks bigger power in the wood day
cutter ah a tree has fallen in the
forest and it is made of sin but not me
a sinner that I assure thee thou claim
to be without sin none of us is without
sins but mine do not run
then whose look for my brother nice
brother specins of Three Brothers one
who lies one who sells truth and one
honks this is Fairy talk nothing has
honking in this land since mother duck
laid the big egg no honking since then
no sire
[Music]
interesting something is rotten in The
Woodcutter I am murderer the perversions
of its source speak me to me of
perversions I have nothing to say for I
do not tarry with them
what do thou telling me I am troubled by
the murder of it I know no thing I want
thee my forgiveness makes no room for
liars that will do what thou mascara I
have no doubt that brother speaking of
Three Brothers I do not honk in sire I
swear in upon it never thou hast thou
honken never never it is a sin in my
eyes
so who's honking
who's hungry now lie about honking what
say thy Brothers honking hot
that would slide in the cutter of the
wood without woods do murder in the wood
I thou hath it right I sought only to
distracting thee while I make in my
Escape goodbye cutter do not run from me
tree
you're not running thou do not run nay I
grow it in 100 years I will hath grown
so tall and strong thine ax will never
fell in me
foreign
well that was
[Music]
all right okay all right big rod in the
wood today cutter and wait what no
that's not me now don't talk like that
oh I got a hat upgrade this is the ERA
with which to walk around and wear off
the door I just want to say that it it
really is it is actually I'm going back
to Grady nice hat thanks
yours is all right
it's not that great actually anyway can
I go to bed now how'd it go it worked I
think I had some crazy dream there was a
Woodcutter that was me I guess in these
talking trees and one of them had sinned
you know what never mind some kind of
crazy dream is blending for me okay good
night
ah what's that
old Ragdoll must have been left walk
away from the Shelf all right all right
lots of empty space in here you should
try to acquire a bunch of random crap to
clutter it up with oh maybe I will
simple writing desk ah unpack
what the hell
my clothes my stuff
you've Stamped Out the Flames but it's a
total loss everything you own has been
reduced to Ash ah everything except
bizarrely the stamp from Murray's letter
ah it's got a picture of a cute dog
weirdly it isn't even charged is it
cursed is it is that stamp cursed
hard you can't even work on the door and
I'm all right it's absolute I guess
[Music]
oh boy
all right a dream about school wow
look at this it's a dream hi what lots
of people in the hallways it seems hello
how's it going
[Music]
Locker is
all right check the seventh one there
isn't a seven I said check it
[Music]
fill with old school papers what kind of
papers they got your name on them and
you're your papers all right how I spend
my summer by Markiplier age six this
summer I visited my Uncle Murray Uncle
Murray's funny he knows magic I had a
fun time with Uncle Murray the end look
onto the platers
no an overdue library book checked out
13 years ago and I've spent the last 12
years and 50 weeks feeling slightly
guilty about not returning it okay
whatever six Locker opens vast on
carrying some empty space okay fifth one
cookbooks all in French empty Babe Ruth
peanut butter
thriving Colony events that was a waste
of time okie dokie then hi
bran with govunculus hello you must be
eplier monk who's asking I'm your
academic advisor it's time for you to
choose your class but I dropped out in
real life certainly you must however
choose a class I don't understand
oh I get it that's why I pick up a
character class now then three classes
there's Advanced kicking and throwing
this class is for pigskiness we have the
overview of kurd Turner Conjuring this
is a class for cheese wizards weird time
signatures 504 this is of course for
jazz agents I really like cheese
I like cheese a lot a strange Chef
magi's cheese wizards use their
intellect and mysticality to accomplish
their goals in combat they wield hard
Elemental cheeses to damage their foes
and soft soothing cheeses to heal
himself I really like cheese
like I have an unhealthy relationship
with cheese
I love cheese I'll be a cheese weathers
which wizard brilliant now then there's
just a minor matter of your minor
it looks like you've already completed
it but it doesn't say what you studied
cryptobotany applied insectology I like
the psychology of rocks ah
psychogeologist so you know a lot about
rocks and the gems and their hopes and
dreams oh yeah
oh oh yeah I believe we're done feel
free to wake up
just go through that door
thank you
ah Shady cool
am I oh geez withered now
don't look too closely all right fair
enough only way to interact with your
inventory during your dream is if you
convince Freddy to hold it for you at
the exact moment you went to sleep who's
Freddy I did that yeah I did I was ready
to hold all my stuff and he said yes you
don't even know Freddy all right
fine nice lady says that this doorway
leads back to your Waking Life all right
I'm awake now
Ray I'm a cheese Wizard and all my stuff
exploded I just remembered
that's very sad hi Jessica how'd you
sleep oh my clothes burned up in a freak
luggage fire oh geez that's weird and
unfortunate you seem less surprised by
it than I would expect we've gotten
accustomed to weird and unfortunate
stuff happening around here you can pick
out some clothes from the shop out front
if you don't mind looking like someone's
Dusty old grandpa once you get the sleep
out of your eyes I got another mission
for you another curse thing yeah I've
had my eye on it for a while but it
keeps moving around most of the readings
put a local Speakeasy at the back of an
alley at the other end of the block the
artifact isn't there right now but
that's where I'd start looking maybe you
can pick up some Clues okay what am I
looking for just to be a watch of some
kind a pocket watch or maybe a
wristwatch I can't be certain alright
watch in the alley you'll need the
password for the Speakeasy it's
Fiddlesticks also let me give you a
checklist
chanted so it always shows you
whatever's written on the chalkboard
here
oh mate oh that's ominous but thanks why
is it ominous in case things get rough
that's why it's ominous I should read
till the end
[Music]
but what this wasn't here before was it
antique bookshelf man came by this
morning Charles couldn't resist the deal
I can't believe I slept through the
antique bookshelf man all books are in
Latin never learned Latin myself so who
knows if it's a history of Roman Empire
we got their pornography could be both
you know any Latin
we that's Latin for little right so you
know a little uh
cheese I have smells that's pretty good
Magna
wow thank you squint at it
now is not the time best squinting Feats
of great stench there's an epilogue but
due to a misprint ah oh it'll upgrade
the queso fustolento that I just did oh
overdue library book I didn't even know
I had it all right I need to get
something for the cat
chapter one oh my God I forgot that was
all the prologue
I was totally lost in the story that I
completely had forgotten about
everything and let me go here hi
how are you
good to see you hello fellow War
Enthusiast I'm Herschel Herschel wood I
don't really one whoa I hate War
actually I wouldn't say I'm an
Enthusiast can I interest you and find
Historical memorabilia ask about the
dubious grenades they're fine probably
why doesn't the box say fine grenades
then
field research sure dubious Cola Wars
grenade all right just try them out next
time you get in a fight when you're all
done come back and let me know how it
went okay what's for sale oh [ __ ] I need
some heat armor if you have it parmesan
missile
oh yeah uh unfortunately not anything
that I can do so I'm not gonna do
anything about it all right goodbye what
was I what was my good thing I have a
to-do list oh yeah that's right that's
right
they almost got me there you almost got
me all right
you weave between the various trash cans
and piles of uncanned trash until you
reach a serious looking door password
fiddlesticks
Flappy back
fifty snacks
fishy drinks
flippy tricks
fingertips
Fiddlesticks I guess come on in but you
better not be a pro he I don't even know
what a pro he is
Speak Easy friend oh hey isn't it you
guys yeah there's a Fishman from the
watchful eye man he's really going for
it all right good job keep it up uh I
guess I could have fought you before but
hi remember me beat it bud we're off the
clock
I didn't realize you could talk I can
talk about anything you like Dickens
Flubber bruntus what can you tell me
about brontes books are too long
flabberg books are too long books are
too long what books are the right leg
none all right cool
it was nice talking to you hi
uh
uh leave him to his milkiness oh you're
gonna have a drink there you go the lake
is deep enough to drown dreams but not
the sins of the grandfather
wow for those who can read them the
signs are there right here in this very
room I I see I think
they try but they'll never damn up the
flow
huh
okay all right okay
oh there it is
there it is
there it is anyway hey are you really
giving it for him hey can I talk to you
about something
hey you Oliver
oh heck no fancy Dan the cocktail man
hey do you have a watch ah the only one
who barely carries a pocket watch is the
owner Oliver Gluck and he left about an
hour ago to pick up our latest ship in a
hooch for moo remove baby before I was
fancy Dan the cocktail man I was fancy
Dan the English teacher oh sorry from
whom From the Mob guys we always get it
from wither went
wither went Oliver the old refrigerator
Factory how do I get there uh uh
cocktail napkin answered thanks wrong
napkin grabs a different one with icons
mapkin wow okay I have a napkin we're
here behind Murray's store on Plunkett
street so if you go out the alley and
then head straight for the edge of the
napkin you can miss Factory well thank
you this is very helpful I'm definitely
not a pro he
give me beer
hell yeah
all right cool you've had better beer
but you definitely had worse beer
got another drink
well thank you
all right thank you goodbye can I yeah
talk to you about something
spit related obviously on a first date
and you shouldn't bother them well I've
never been obvious about everything some
weird symbols are carved on one of the
floor tiles those are the same ones from
the guy in the train car I think it's
weirdly responsible for this illegal
poison dispensary to have a first aid
kit Ah that's Andy
hi making ethereal music with
Spirit-filled glasses okay all right
come with me gabby because I imagine I'm
gonna have to fight someone eventually
in daylight it's clear this bank has
been closed for some time the door to
the bank has been fastened with three
locks that is the maximum possible level
of security what about four what about
four locks four lock systems are still
dismissed as unachievable liberal
fantasy what's under the welcome map
not a bad idea but if you're gonna lift
the bulk of Mag you need to know what
you're looking for first how much stuff
can be under a welcome mat oh
well all right oh thank you okay uh
sneaky peek he turns over in this lock
but nothing happens something sneaky
about this Pete all right how about meth
upon
interesting
interesting
interesting I need to have high stats to
be able to do there walk somewhere else
sure fridge Factory
hobo nods pleasantly as he passed tips
his head howdy fella my name is Stevie
Garcia I haven't been able to find work
in town any chance you could spare seven
meets so I can buy some caviar I'd be
really grateful caviar not just say a
sandwich well I'm high I figure I don't
know what I call Seven meat caviar but
it isn't Aiming High all right there you
go I am a good egg thank you very much
I'm pretty good egg hi what is going on
here
this has obviously been stolen and
dragged here ah looks like they're here
for some serious business I also am here
for serious business private party club
members only yeah club members only kind
of Club Fraternal Order of people who
bribed us more than we're earn
Ed bum egg I've never heard of it
how do I join what do you think I'd have
thought it was obvious pal you give us
me how much 500 500 told you to knock
off that repeating business let's see
how am I supposed to come up with that
kind of meat how about a beating instead
how about a beating instead
oh
my kneecap why do you get to go first
um I have this Cola uh
uh is there any one of you guys I can
kill with the cola ah you'll die with
the cola probably
take this
oh frick
oh why let me try this instead take this
queso fustolino
I'm gonna die but at least I can try
something here
and this should kill you although I'm
gonna die
[Music]
interesting
thank you Gabby no not Gabby's goon not
my kneecap oh my Crow why would you hit
a bird all right I'm gonna try this
again it's definitely gonna work this
time
holy crap it worked I can't believe it
worked take this queso fustamento yeah
uh
sure
you're gonna kneek at me aren't you
[Music]
no not her goon no Gabby no well this is
a problem
you punch real hard in the Goon
but if I lower your everything
this is a this is not the best
situation to be in I don't think I
should use all of my items
this turn
yeah I'm gonna I'll probably go for a
loss here and then in the next one I'll
actually use my items because I use if I
use all my items here and it's just a
loss anyway then I'm not gonna do
anything my goon ow
my kneecap
[Music]
well don't worry oh
you realize that winning is better than
losing and you resolve to do better in
the future oh
oh
I'll do that one to maximum AP wow take
it good thing I lost I'll take care of
the beating wow
my moxie
all right but this time
this time it's gonna go good ER than it
did before
because
I'm gonna throw this at you I'm gonna
heave this at you
take that and then I'm gonna heave this
Oh I thought I could use one more combat
item but it's fine because I'm gonna use
this at you
and finish off you
yep and then this to flip you
foreign
oh wait did I have one more AP oh crap I
didn't do that right now I'm super dumb
my goon no no well my bird
you shrugged interesting interesting
stupid
idiot dumb
you fool you fool fool
[ __ ]
you're dumb
all right
foreign
take another
and another
oh
that's a lot of stats
that's a lot of that's a lot of stats
how did you why you get so no
you got how did you get so many no
[Music]
you telling me
foreign
I swear angry
oh I'm God I'm not gonna beat you you're
gonna get it this time I'm gonna kick
you in the air ass
that was your first mistake get ready
for your second
grenade this is gonna happen oh God son
of a [ __ ]
huh
why is it only doing two damage I feel
like it should do more than two damage
no
this is definitely gonna work this time
all right wow it worked I can't believe
it
[Music]
oh boy
oh wow please work
holy crap it works but I think I'm still
gonna die
um
boy I wish I had you're gonna punch me
for 14 damage why do you have so much in
everything uh cause you stat it up you
big [ __ ]
well now I'm contemplative I take a
moment you son of a [ __ ] you think
you're better than me
there we go that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm talking about
all right okay I can take this punch oh
the bird can take the punch definitely
that helps a lot
don't you do it
oh I can see exactly what they're
intending to do that is helpful I I
probably should have known about that
way way sooner you're gonna punch me for
eight you're gonna punch Gabby for nine
well I can't just stand by and allow
that to happen
I'm going to use this to
heal you
I really shoved that in your gob
okay this is where it's gonna go five
stench damage
it's not ideal
but it'll do
[Music]
oh should just be able to get it one
more go of things
[Music]
all right so you're gonna hit me you're
gonna hit me so I don't need to heal
Gabby because you're gonna die
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes this is it
this is it this is it good excellent
good good emit
emit
you're done you're done for you're done
[Music]
that's okay that's okay that's okay I'll
avenge you I'll avenge you gab I'll
avenge you and I've Avenged you you're
dead you're dead all of you are dead
[Music]
that was impressive thank you very much
definitely didn't take me 10 000 times
all right anyway good stuff mag Magic
ah refrigerator took two counts as a
fleet they have a whole Fleet of these
things really cold what do you mean it's
cold how cold could oh refrigerant is
refrigerator I guess it's a
refrigeration 11 in one oil according to
the fine print 11 of the world's little
religions are actually part of a
larger-seeker religion understood only
by the old man who owns the company that
makes the oil
oh
okay do I drink that for a Moxie okay
sharpening stone ah
good hoping this door would make a lot
of noise and draw a lot of attention
also you don't know how to open it okay
good am I supposed to be being secret
here
brand new empty kind of boring make some
stuff I don't I can't make anything okay
oh I got stuff
oh can I make stuff now all right looks
like something's going down over there
is that all it's all there the 40 cases
it's all there Gluck you got the meat
whoa
dark Noel what surprise inspection what
and what
what
what
what
what
seems to be a bit of a standoff between
the mob guys and the other ones
lady in the weird crimbo hat glares of
you as you approach I don't recall
inviting you to this party are you gonna
introduce yourself
any business
what's wrong with your hat nothing at
all karimbo hat is appropriate for All
Seasons it's all spooky in the lake
it's cutting a hole in the world you
could see stars for it so spooky and
like
just super spooky
I'm sure I have no idea what you mean
Oliver dear are you busy
be a deer and kill this guy oh
um Oliver you okay look it's gonna be
fine Whoa man uh hello
ah
Shadows begin together random abstract
menacing shapes ah hey mob guys can I
get you to give me a hand with this
considering the newly terrifying Mr
Gluck is between us and the exit seems
like we got no choice all right yeah man
thanks guys Shadow bite oh
boy
I'm not sure I understand anything of
what's going on it's a shadowy slab
I don't even know what that means I'm a
blasted hello
all right I did it
I seem to understand where the Shadows
over Shadows of loathing comes from
take this oh
what did you just do to Gabby no
no Oh I thought you were going for Gabby
oh I was almost worried for a second
there I mean that guy did have the gun
and that probably is kind of important
Shadow Oliver Gluck intends to touch
temporary mob Ally dealing ah well
at least you got a hit out
um let me at least I was just gonna kill
this thing because it deserves it
[Music]
hey yeah
oh oh
God no so spooky I'm guessing I'm gonna
probably be fine you're gonna touch the
ren I mean horrible don't do that
no average fine it's fine slap him give
him a good slap nice
take this oh one away no
no I'm fine slap him
Wham nice
Shadow creatures defeated the two mob
guys brush themselves off woo this
Capers got me all balled up and now this
whole scene is nutty as a squirrel's
mistress come on let's say I'm spray
they dip their hats to you and make for
the door if escapes was left of that guy
he's mostly dissolved into a cloud of
that weird Shadow stuff but there are a
few objects on the ground a pocket watch
a bank pouch and an official looking
document of some sort
well it's just wrong and uh Bank pass
full of meat and deed to the Speak Easy
it's mine
it's mine turns out the Gluck guy was
the owner of the Speakeasy and now you
are maybe is that how Deeds work yeah
[Music]
yeah
booze looks dangerous and that also
appears to be tainted with some kind of
sinister magical energy
fridge is plugged in experimental not
for lunches
fridge has been fitted with an
experimental automatic ice cube maker
unfortunately it's one made one single
gigantic guys keep that fills the entire
fridge I guess you never need a block of
ice as big as you here's where you can
get it if I ever need a block of ice as
big as me I'm going to remember that
because I'm sure in the future I'm going
to need to block advice as big as me you
don't have to leave the building to open
your map by the way you can just click
the map
go back to Plunkett Street well I feel
like walking so shut up also
I feel like ending the episode because
that's all the time I have thank you
everybody so much for watching get ready
for more Shadows overloathing because we
now know what the Shadows are that are
in loathing or over it rather they're
actually right behind you look out look
ah
[Music]
thank you